how'd it feel you uh had quite a few
trophies to hold in your hand over there
yeah yes a lot yeah I've never done that
I don't know how people do that and it
looks comfortable but I managed some
somehow and let it be known for the
record you chose your bathroom break
after you won ah yeah I learned I
learned from my mistakes
thank you very much the moment your name
was called you grabbed your drink you
chugged it in a beautiful award goes to
[Applause]
what was going through your mind I
like I'm briefed on things like I
there's things that I know like I'm
nominated and things like that and like
stay here you might get but my mind is
in other places like oh my God Janet
Jackson was 10 feet away from me and oh
my God Mary J Blige has been 10 feet
away from me for the last like how long
have we been here and and so like my
mind's on everything else but then when
it happens it's like and then yeah I
mean I don't know I I I was I was
shocked and I and I I ran up I was like
I need something because I feel like my
first speech was flat a little bit so I
don't know
um yeah it was great it was amazing it's
an honor I've always loved r b growing
up it's what raised me
thank you guys so much and
you right I
now that the night is almost over you
have all your Awards to take home how
are you gonna celebrate
uh bathtub
a bathtub kick the shoes off and get
into the toe yeah
[Music]